Speaker 1: There is a huge scientific and societal
pressure that's growing on the covid-19 AXA's that
are still refusing to get the coronavirus
vaccine, as we are now starting to see more
than half of the United States see an increase in
cases, thanks mostly to the very contagious Delta
variant spreading in particular among unvaccinated
people. And of course, because no vaccine is
100 percent effective of the covid vaccines that
we currently have. By sheer math, also picking off
some people who did do the right thing and did
go and get themselves vaccinated. And so it's
overwhelmingly happening in the least vaccinated
counties. This is translating to happening more in
red states than in blue states. And yesterday, I
already told you about the stunning numbers which
show that in May I mean, look at this, in May,
ninety nine point two percent of those who died
of coronavirus were not vaccinated, while
zero point eight percent of those who died
had been vaccinated. Maryland says that 100
percent of covid-19 deaths last month were among
the unvaccinated. So this is this is no joke. The
numbers are to call them overwhelming is really
an understatement. And it's getting so bad. In
other words, the impact of not being vaccinated
is so huge on a country or a state or even on
a county health system that people are going
crazy trying to figure out what is it going to
take to get people vaccinated so that we can
stop the development of new variants and the
evolution of new variants and stop the spread
among mostly unvaccinated people, but
still affecting the vaccinated as well,
because no vaccine is 100 percent effective now
in the United States. We're not going to see
government mandatory vaccinations. Employers
can certainly legally require employees to be
vaccinated, in most cases to go back to an
in-person working situation. Some countries
are taking a much more authoritarian approach.
We're not going to see this in the United States.
But Tajikistan and the Vatican are imposing
mandatory vaccination on adults straight
up period. In Italy, there are several
counties or territories that have imposed
mandatory vaccination on certain sections of the
population. Italian doctors and health workers in
both the public and private sector must be
vaccinated or they will face not being allowed
to work directly with patients, which will make
it really difficult for them to do their jobs.
The British government in
mid-June said all home care staff
must be fully vaccinated to continue working.
Kazakhstan on July 1st ordered mandatory
coronavirus vaccinations for a wide range of
workers who come into contact with others. Now,
in the United States, we're not going to see that.
I'm not an advocate of that. I am an advocate
of people getting vaccinated and we have
to figure out how to get them to do it.
We have some examples in the US, like the city of
San Francisco, they've said it's going to require
municipal employees to be vaccinated or they could
face penalties up to and including dismissal.
But that's only when there's full FDA approval of
the vaccine. Houston Methodist Hospital in Texas,
more than one hundred and fifty employees
have been fired or resigned because they
didn't comply with their employer directive to
get themselves vaccinated. The Delta variant.
Is less well handled by the current vaccines,
and we're already seeing a more contagious lambda
variant appear in Australia. We still don't know
that much about it. So like this is the key time.
Do we want a resurgence of this in the fall? Do we
want to have to go back this fall to the direction
of hopefully not as bad, but the direction
of the way things were last fall? And yes,
almost half of the US reports of U.S. states are
reporting rising cases largely because of this
Delta variant. About one hundred and fifty seven
million Americans right now. Fifty eight percent
of us adults are fully vaccinated. Sixty
seven percent of US adults have had at least
one shot. We are getting there. We did not meet
meet Joe Biden's goal of 70 percent by July 4th,
hopefully by next this weekend or early next week.
We will get to that point. But what is it going
to take to get these people vaccinated? Because
otherwise it will be more variance and more spread
and eventually it will be more deaths as well. If
we get a variant that really evades the vaccines
and has a higher death rate. Understand
that. To say that we've been lucky about
anything in this pandemic, it feels crass.
It feels outrageous to say. But I encourage
you to read Lawrence Wright's latest book, The
End of October. It's a novel. It's fiction,
but it's clearly based around a coronavirus like
global pandemic. We're lucky that the real world
coronavirus for now doesn't have nearly the death
rate that the imaginary virus in Lawrence Wright's
book the end of October has. Because if we had
and we could have a much more deadly variant,
the numbers will be even more horrifying than
what the US and the world has already endured. So
what will it take to get these folks vaccinated?
I know about a third of them say if there is full
FDA approval, I will go and get vaccinated.
That's about a third of the currently vaccine,
hesitant based on a poll from a few weeks ago. Do
I believe a full third of them are really going to
get vaccinated when there's FDA approval? No,
I imagine some will say, OK, well, let me now
give it a few months that it's been FDA approved
fully rather than just as emergency use. Some of
them will. Some of them won't. What will it take
to get more people vaccinated at this point? I
don't know. Will it be required vaccinations
to go to sporting events? Will it be required
vaccinations to travel? A lot of these folks don't
travel anyway. I don't know what the answer is,
but it's very scary. And we are seeing in the
numbers what we could be facing very, very soon